[Música]
[Aplausos]
acho que todo mundo aqui tinha grandes
expectativas antes de entrar na
faculdade ainda tem grande expectativa
do que vai vir a ser a faculdade e todos
pararam pra pensar no que vão se formar
com a necessária da faculdade é eu
descobri que não fazer ideia eu tinha
duas grandes expectativas
a primeira era uma boa aluna tirar notas
boas me apaixonar pelo meu curso e me
tornar uma grande profissional de harry
de produção
a segunda era aprender muito sobre
várias áreas do conhecimento
eu queria fazer várias matérias de mil
prédios diferentes sabe o tanto de coisa
no primeiro semestre a última disciplina
de introdução à engenharia onde a cada
aula a gente era apresentado a um
trajeto de extensão diferente e hora
acabou empolgada eu queria fazer tudo e
eu acabei decidindo pela empresa júnior
é uma empresa gerida pelos estudantes e
que para serviços reais à sociedade o
que me encontrou foi a questão da
capacitação profissional que é muito
promovida pela empresa júnior
eu pensei que eu entrar aprendeu tanto
cabulosa colocar no meu currículo e é
ótimo
realmente eu estava aprendendo tanto com
as pessoas lá dentro
aquela com certeza está contribuindo com
o objetivo de me tornar um grande
profissional e eu comecei a pensar que
talvez pra atividade queria que os
conhecimentos técnicos de outras áreas
que eu queria eu poderia conhecer
pessoas de outros cursos e assim em
patins de meus tempos o objetivo foi
assim que atuei pelo núcleo de empresas
juniores da ufmg
o núcleo é a organização que conecta
representa e desenvolve as empresas
menores daqui da ufmg e lá eu comecei a
conviver com pessoas de vários cursos
diferentes
estava encantada com a forma que elas
pensavam como era totalmente diferente
de mim e das pessoas do meu curso estava
impressionada com as coisas que elas
sabiam e como eu estava aprendendo com
elas mas aí o google fechou e ele acabou
se perdendo o seu propósito e as
empresas de janeiro decidiram que ele
deveria encerrar suas atividades às
pessoas que trabalham lá não estavam
mais muito engajados no trabalho nem
mesmo para quem a gente faz das
atividades estava interessando
em um dos últimos eventos que a gente
fez só uma pessoa apareceu
foi quando pensei e agora eu não teria
mais oportunidade de trabalho e as
pessoas são sensacionais e meus amigos
não teriam a chance também e todas as
outras pessoas que não têm a
oportunidade de conviver e trabalhar tão
facilmente com pessoas de outros cursos
e também o que estava deixando de ser
construído
eu comecei a ficar curiosa com a
possibilidade de lutar pelas pessoas tão
sensacionais e tentar fazer alguma coisa
muito grande e restringir a correção de
reestruturação do núcleo é formado por
pessoas de algumas empresas juniores
para tentar reconstruir o núcleo ea
gente começou do nada sem expectativas
sobre nosso trabalho sem apoio das
empresas mas fomos começamos fazendo
coisas simples e pensar em coisas
pequenas mas o que importava era que a
gente estava fazendo e eu continuava
segue até realmente acreditando que eu
tinha que dar certo é gente boa querendo
fazer coisa grande e ainda pode os meses
a gente fez uma eleição um processo
seletivo e pronto parecia que tava tudo
arrumado mas o desafio pela frente ainda
era grande a gente começa a planejar o
semestre sempre com frio na barriga
achei que ia dar certo mesmo é que as
pessoas envolveriam se elas iam gostar
do que a gente estava criando a gente
realmente queria fazer alguma coisa
diferente e aí no primeiro evento que a
gente fez
a gente encontrou no auditório 100
pessoas muito animadas com que a gente
estava criando e que foi muito
importante pois a gente vê que ele
estava indo no caminho certo
a gente faz um encontro de líderes que
vamos sucesso
juntamos os diretores de dar várias
empresas juniores e eles começaram a
trocar compartilhou trocar conhecimentos
e compartilhar experiências e começar a
perceber que eles realmente poderiam
contar uns com os outros e assim fez uma
dinâmica bem engraçadas as pessoas
realmente se conectaram a gente promover
uma competição esportiva para que as
pessoas pudessem se conhecer dilma com
mais leve e dinâmica espontânea e
professor
eram pessoas de empresas juniores
totalmente diferentes e nem se conheciam
e agora estavam jogando juntas intime
promovemos um evento de pré aceleração
dos ataques que muita gente teve
oportunidades o primeiro contato
empreendedorismo esperam colocar a mão
na massa tiveram que começar o
empreendedor de bh e realmente criar uma
startup em algumas semanas
e aí com o tempo as pessoas começaram a
se sentir parte daquilo eu estava vendo
gente que eu nem conhecia andando com a
camisa do núcleo e adesivos
as pessoas estão interagindo mais e eu
realmente comecei a ver a amizade
surgindo
eu estava completamente meta nesse mundo
e viu quando eu estava crescendo com
aquelas pessoas e aprender algumas
coisas bem práticas habilidades e
competências importantes na minha vida
profissional estava aprendendo sobre
liderança porque eu tinha que rodar o
meu carro o trabalho da minha equipe o
trabalho do núcleo também e eu estava
vendo a cada dia que aquela mobilidade
que eu ia aprender na sala de aula no
livro eu trabalhava com pessoas
completamente diferentes de mim de
outros cursos e com histórias muito
diferentes
isso me ensinou muito sobre como lidar
com perfis diferentes desenvolver a
comunicação porque eu tinha que falar em
público em todos os eventos do lucro
me tornei uma pessoa mais organizada e
mais produtiva também estava bem
satisfeita está aprendendo essas coisas
porque era parte dos meus objetivos mas
aí eu comecei a formar uma percepção
diferente sobre o ambiente ao redor
sobre algumas coisas que eu estava
fazendo
eu acabei conhecendo ufmg quase toda
porque eu tinha que ir para outros
prédios para fazer uma reunião o meu
saco alguém e é que eu posso fazer parte
da minha rotina eu gosto eu passei a
gostar de ir para outros prédios estudar
em outras bibliotecas de conhecer novos
cantinho de novos caminhos e ver que as
pessoas diferentes todos os dias e
participar um pouco do que aconteceu
naqueles espaços ver algumas exposições
alguns debates que estava acontecendo
tava realmente mudando meu jeito de ver
o mundo
comecei a entender melhor como respeitar
pensamentos diferentes que estavam ao
redor das culturas diferentes que a
gente tem dentro de uma universidade tão
grande porque cada prédio tem seu jeito
de ver o mundo
e através de algumas pessoas eu pude
entender melhor sobre essas visões e
quebrar os preconceitos
a cada dia que passava eu conhecer mais
pessoas e penso bem olha o jogador olha
o tanto de gente maravilhosa que a gente
tem na universidade entre as pesquisas
que as pessoas desenvolvem nos projetos
que elas fazem parte dos trabalhos e
provas que elas fazem nos sonhos que
elas têm eu ficava muito impressionada e
muito orgulhosa de fazer parte daquele
poder conhecer algumas daquelas pessoas
eu estava me sentindo mais acolhida na
universidade
gente olha tímida com a cara fechada
tenho um amigo meu sempre fala isso ano
quando a gente conhece
a sessão estava fechada e agora está
sempre indo eu estava passando a dar
sempre rindo porque eu estava me
sentindo em casa na ufmg eu tinha amigos
conhecidos em cada prédio eu não me
sentir mais sozinho como no início do
curso
eu estava me sentindo a corrida tudo que
estava acontecendo ao meu redor me fez
perceber que eu estava mudando muito
eu estava começando a pensar fora da
lógica colégio faculdade emprego
apresentador começando a entender que eu
podia e eu queria fazer muito mais que
isso
comecei alguns até alguns dos maiores da
minha vida porque estava descobrindo
quem eu era e percebendo que eu podia
viver a minha vida do meu jeito e não
como me dizem para fazer isso
eu estava ficando muito mais interessada
pelo meu trabalho eu não to do que por
qualquer uma das minhas matérias muito
mais interessado nas vidas que a gente
estava transformando nos eventos que
estava fazendo do que por qualquer prova
percebendo que aqueles projectos é
aquele tipo de organização fazer muito
mais sentido pra mim do que qualquer
sala de aula que eu tinha vivido
eu estava gostando muito de conviver e
trabalhar com aquelas pessoas que sempre
teve um olhar muito diferente do meu
porque a gente construir
é incrível ver como que com as
potencialidades talento de cada um a
gente conseguia criar coisas que talvez
nenhum de nós queria sozinho eu estava
aprendendo muito sobre mim mesma o meio
das conversas que eu tinha da
convivência do trabalho com as pessoas
estava descobrindo que era boa coisa
meus pontos fracos e como é que podia
melhorar
descobrir que eu gosto muito da palestra
nem negociar parcerias mas que era ótima
com planilhas e que gostava muito de
gestão de pessoas
a forma como que a conexão entre as
pessoas e acontecendo é muito legal
aquilo realmente estava me deixando
encantada
eu sempre pensava como fazer as pessoas
do time interagirem e como as pessoas
colaborarem em 35 e é incrível pensar
como aquelas conexões poderiam mudar
suas vidas
caso os braços em amigos namorado sócios
estamos aprendendo umas com as outras
ela se inspirassem umas nas outras bom
mas tem que aprender sobre várias áreas
do conhecimento
é eu estava aprendendo muito sobre
várias áreas do conhecimento
mas eu estava aprendendo a pensar
diferente e é isso na verdade que eu
queria que ele entender se os tipos
diferentes de ter contato com outras
formas de ver o mundo
só que isso aconteceu de uma forma que
eu não esperava que eu imaginava que
existia era por meio das pessoas e do
jeito de pensar delas por meio da
experimentação a cadeia e assento meus
projetos
a cada viagem a cada equipe que
trabalhava com a cada palestra conversa
discussão era assim que estava me
tornando a pessoa que eu queria ser e há
três anos e meio eu venho tentando me
formar em engenharia de produção mas
informando mesmo em conectar pessoas e
amar e realizar projeto que transforma a
vida das pessoas
pensar com quem pensa diferente e me
conhecer e por causa dessa segunda
informações
eu tive a oportunidade de trabalhar com
o desenvolvimento de tratados em belo
horizonte com negócios sociais com
eventos coisas que eu nunca imaginaria
quando eu entrei na faculdade curso
o doutor nem só no curso certo
eu acho que não mas está valendo tudo
muito a pena e que estou me formando com
muito mais uma baixaram qualquer coisa
transformando como pessoa descobriram
que eu sou o que eu quero ser
essas coisas que eu aprendi na sala de
aula e eu quero levar daqui
essas formações o de bono e todas as
outras que eu conheço e fora da sala de
aula
neste mundo de possibilidades em que
você quer se formar
[Aplausos]
[Música]